on s'en fout parce que à part les
Bogdanov qui a une maison de vacances
dans les faubourgs Tchernobyl
en plus pour elle est belle la vie
bon qu'est-ce qui mobilise les Français
en ce moment bah c'est ceci bah oui bah
du pain et des jeux de la tradie et du
ski alors j'ai fait l'effort j'ai
regardé quelques épreuves des Jeux alors
il y a un truc sur lequel on ment pas
c'est vraiment des épreuves
mais déjà regardé un truc comme le
combiné ce qu'ils te font le seul homme
c'est pas facile mais en plus se taper
l'interview du vainqueur après
je suis super content c'est plus beau
jour de ma vie c'est trop une belle
aventure attends mon gars une belle
aventure c'est de réussir à trouver un
stage rémunéré ça c'est une aventure
alors forcément les journalistes
sportifs sur enchérissent les Jeux
Olympiques c'est quand même ce gros
moment où tu aimerais savoir ce qui se
passe dans la tête d'un journaliste
sportif
quand tu n'es pas assez doué pour
l'action bon tu fais journaliste quand
tu es pas assez doué pour faire
journaliste tu fais journaliste sportif
ça va vous avez évité de peu mais
maintenant chose plus sérieuse vous
l'avez appris Ukraine
après le printemps arabe l'hiver slave
attention attention en Ukraine le
mouvement des Frères orthodoxes peut
arriver au pouvoir je déconne et en
Europe
non sérieusement qu'est-ce qui se passe
parce que ça mérite une analyse
géopolitique alors le vrai problème de
l'Ukraine ce sont ses voisins ce que je
veux dire ça jamais été simple entre les
syllabes et les bordures
et puis entre nous on s'en fout parce
qu'à part les Bogdanov qui a une maison
de vacances dans les faubourgs
c'est vrai c'est une tragédie mais je
comprends moi je comprends que ce
conflit déchaîne pas plus les passions
on peut pas s'identifier pas ce sont des
gens extrêmement suspects ils veulent
rentrer dans l'Europe
mais là il y a des morts et c'est vrai
que c'est pas tout y'a pire l'opposition
souffre de quelque chose de beaucoup
plus grave elle a reçu le soutien de BHL
avec en BHL 100 ml si on dirait un film
de blakedwards c'est BHL c'est
l'inspecteur Clouzeau des relations
internationales
sauf que clouzo en foutant le bordel il
arrivait quand même à faire dégager le
méchant c'est un peu la seule ah bon
c'est la partie triste amour parce qu'il
faut aussi être un peu heureux n'est ce
pas Giroud le footballeur qui s'est fait
choper avec une escort-girl enfin est-ce
qu'on peut parler de tromperie une
escort-girl et un footballeur c'est pas
de l'infidélité c'est du baby-sitting
c'est
le mec qui se sent obligé de s'excuser
ah je demande pardon à mon équipe ma
famille mon entraîneur mes coéquipiers
les supporters d'Arsenal non mais
Olivier quand tu trompes ta femme tu vas
pas t'excuser auprès de ton pote sauf si
c'est la sienne
je dois me battre pour ma famille mon
club rien d'autre ne compte désormais
arrête Olivier tu as tiré un coup et si
tu fais des excuses comme si tu étais
responsable la victoire de Hollande aux
présidentielles non c'est pas grave
[Applaudissements]
je vais dire Olivier regarde moi dans
les yeux
il faut que tu arrêtes de croire qu'une
femme va te quitter parce que tu la
trompe olive si elle t'aime elle peut
même gérer les raisins de l'hôtel pour
tes prochains 5 à 7
si elle t'aime elle veut ton bonheur
réfléchis tu crois pas que c'est plutôt
elle de s'excuser de sa possessivité
maladive
tu es maltraité Olivier mais tu ne t'en
rends pas compte elle devrait être super
rassurée elle devrait se dire il me
trompe avec une femme ouf
voilà c'est un mec enfin c'est un mec
c'est pas un mec pour tous quoi
en revanche les scores un peu con
vraiment elle a une drôle de manière
vouloir se faire un réseau bonjour tu
veux coucher avec moi c'est possible
c'est pas très cher mais en revanche je
me rattrape sur les produits dérivés
photos souvenirs carte postale vidéo
moi un mec comme ça il me change des
autres sportifs là franchement tu sais
que le type là on a parlé lui la vilenie
qui établit un nouveau record soit la
perche
sport de blaireau quoi franchement ah
non mais on en a soupé toute la semaine
le mec il a sauté 6 mètres 16 alors la
question du journaliste peut-il aller
plus haut et lui tout fier ouais je
crois encore gagner 4 cm
en soirée il raconte quoi au gentil
alors toi c'est quoi ton talent bah tu
vois l'immeuble là-bas tu me donnes une
paire j'arrive atterrir dans le salon du
deuxième étage
économie mondebourg strikesback alors
c'est un peu de Chuck Norris fait de
l'économie c'est l'homme qui peut
allumer les fonds de Florange avec une
cigarette électronique
alors l'état viendrater une part dans
Peugeot alors il est super content il a
déclaré je suis fier d'annoncer au
contribuable que désormais ils sont si
propriétaire de Peugeot
Arnaud moi j'en ai pas envie en fait
tu m'aurais dit Ferrari Apple peut-être
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
le décolleté ça passe alors maintenant
[Musique]
politique alors on a un nouveau Premier
ministre vous l'avez même pas révélé
c'est Pierre Gattaz donc il porte un
pin's 1 million d'emplois vu le temps
qui a duré la folie du pin's tu
comprends dans la tête du mec l'emploi
c'est un truc démodé c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment on vit une
situation assez inédite un Jean-Marc
Ayrault il me fait de la peine il me
fait de la Jean-Marc Ayrault c'était
c'est l'homme qui est licencié depuis un
an mais personne ne lui a dit encore
pauvre vieux tu es bien au bureau on dit
mais sinon tout va
troisième âge alors on a finalement levé
l'immunité de Dassault mec qui a racheté
ses voix pour se faire élire je vois pas
ce qu'il y a de choquant là-dedans
aujourd'hui acheter des voix c'est
peut-être le seul moyen de faire
vraiment monter le pouvoir d'achat des
électeurs
on parle de supprimer le régime des
intermittents d'ailleurs je dois dire à
ce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui nous
filment des intermittents moi je
soutiens ce régime c'est très important
pour nous autres les précaires
non moi ça me permet quand même de payer
une partie des impôts avec ça
[Musique]
efmi les Grecs sont en train de sortir
de la crise
alors avec 28% de chômage donc
logiquement on est en plein boom
économique
ah pas belle la vie et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de innarditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu